une visite pas comme les autres samedi
11 mars les Yvelinois de passage au
Petit Moulin des voies de Cernay ont pu
découvrir le bâtiment d'une manière
originale
[Musique]
le bazar culturel théâtre social
itinérant à réaliser une visite
théâtralisée sur le thème du voyage et
de l'identité avec des jeunes cernésiens
et des résidents du centre d'hébergement
d'urgence pour demandeurs d'asile de
Bonnelles c'était vraiment de créer du
mélange entre les cultures et surtout de
trouver un
instant de partage entre chacun on a
tous vécu des événements à un moment qui
ont marqué notre vie quel que soit nos
parcours quel que soit l'endroit où l'on
se trouve la langue qu'on parle et donc
l'idée c'était de retrouver du commun à
partir de ça je vous raconterai aussi
mon histoire
2021 je vis en Colombie j'ai étudié
administration publique Louisa Lopez et
colombienne arrivant en France en
janvier 2022 elle fait partie des cinq
migrants participants à ce projet
culturel j'ai trop que c'est vraiment
l'important c'est super bien parce que
les spectacles aussi nous montre comment
c'est la réalité des différentes
personnes qui avaient des différents
lieux de ces histoires c'est totalement
différent et aujourd'hui on peut trouver
tout le monde ici pour nous compter ceci
ce soir
et pour les aider à compter ces
histoires 5 jeunes de la commune de
Cernay qui ont bien voulu s'ouvrir aux
cultures étrangères
d'autres personnes que potentiellement
je le connaissais pas je sais pas
comment ça se passait au final c'est
très bien passé j'ai passé une très
bonne semaine avec eux le Centre
d'hébergement de demandeurs d'asile de
Bonnelles accueille une centaine de
réfugiés au-delà de l'apprentissage de
la langue française de nombreuses
activités sont mises en place pour les
sortir de leur quotidien comme cette
visite théâtralisée au Petit Moulin des
voies de Cernay